fue la primera vez que su nombre
aparecía en la papeleta desde que asumió
el cargo en una elección que el primer
ministro ahmed calificó de histórica el
partido gobernante de la prosperidad
ganó más del 90 por ciento de los
escaños unos comicios boicoteados por la
oposición y con problemas de logística e
inseguridad que implicaron que una
quinta parte del país no pudiera votar
esto es particularmente en el caso en la
región de tigre una operación de
seguridad iniciada en esta región por el
primer ministro en noviembre se
convirtió en un conflicto devastador
esta guerra llevó a asesinatos masivos y
violaciones ha dejado a 400 mil personas
en situación de hambruna
los enfrentamientos han manchado la
reputación del jefe de estado había me
fue nombrado primer ministro para salvar
la coalición que había estado en el
poder desde 1991 fue considerado un
defensor de la unidad en etiopía un país
formado por 10 regiones semiautónomas
divididas según líneas étnicas y puso
fin a un estancamiento de 20 años
pendientes con eritrea
si el pueblo etíope y el pueblo eritreo
están en paz toda la región del cuerno
de áfrica se puede convertir en una
región de paz y desarrollo y sus
esfuerzos fueron aplaudidos por la
comunidad internacional y significó un
premio nobel para ahmed en 2019 pero la
figura de reformador fue destrozada el
siguiente año
sus críticos ahora lo acusan de liderar
con el mismo estilo autoritario de sus
predecesores